[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen schön dass Sie dabei sind wie
auch Norbert Lehmann für den Sport
ihr könnt euch auf Deutschland verlassen
sagt Bundespräsident Steinmeier bei
seinem Besuch in der Ukraine und sichert
den Menschen im Land anhaltende
Solidarität zu
Kompromiss in Sicht im Streit um den
Einstieg von Chinas staatsräderei kosko
im Hamburger Hafen zeichnet sich eine
Einigung ab
und neuer britischer Premier im Amt
regisunak will das tiefgespaltene Land
einen und die Fehler seiner Vorgängerin
korrigieren
[Musik]
im April noch lehnte die ukrainische
Regierung einen Besuch des
Bundespräsidenten ab damals war sie auf
Deutschland und seinen ehemaligen
Außenminister nicht gut zu sprechen
Steinmeier war mitverantwortlich für die
deutsche russland-politik nach dem
russischen Angriff gestand der
öffentlich Fehler ein heute nun wurde er
in der Ukraine willkommen geheißen und
bekam den Krieg direkt zu spüren Lena
sünderbruch berichtet
es ist der 9 Monat seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffs aber der erste
Besuch von Bundespräsident Steinmeier in
dieser Zeit es sei ein Zeichen der
Solidarität in der Phase der
niederträchtigen russischen Luftangriffe
im ganzen Land sagte am Morgen in Kiel
meine Botschaft an die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer ist wir stehen nicht nur an
eurer Seite sondern wir werden die
Ukraine auch weiterhin unterstützen
wirtschaftlich politisch und auch
militärisch in der Kleinstadt im Norden
des Landes zeigt sich eindrücklich was
der Krieg dort für die Menschen bedeutet
Luftalarm zwingt den Bundespräsidenten
seine Begegnungen mit den Einwohnern in
einen Luftschutzkeller zu verlegen
kojukiwka sei ein Ort in dem die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger viel Mut bewiesen
haben die sich mit bloßen Händen den
Panzern entgegengestellt haben und sie
tatsächlich
zum Stoppen gebracht haben Gespräche mit
Bürgern wie auch hier in einer
Brotfabrik kommen heute in der Ukraine
erst im dritten anlaufzustande
eigentlich wollte Steinmeier das Land
bereits Mitte April besuchen doch
unmittelbar vor Abreise kam die Absage
aus Kiew sie wurde in Berlin als
diplomatischer und politischer affrong
gewertet die Ukraine kreidet Steinmeier
seine russlandfreundliche Politik als
Außenminister an vor allem seine
Unterstützung für die Gaspipeline Nord
Stream 2 in der vergangenen Woche wurde
ein zweiter Versuch aus
Sicherheitsgründen kurzfristig
verschoben nun demonstriert Steinmeier
bei einem Rundgang durch Kiew mit
Bürgermeister Klitschko die Ukraine kann
sich auf Deutschland verlassen das soll
auch bei einem Gespräch mit Präsident
selenski deutlich werden
fragen wir Sarah Hassan CD in Kiew wie
erleben Sie diesen Besuch sind die
Unstimmigkeiten ausgeräumt
das würde ich schon sagen und ich würde
auch betonen dass die meisten
Unstimmigkeiten schon vor dem Besuch
ausgeräumt wurden besonders viel Ärger
gab es ja immer wegen Waffenlieferungen
die Ukraine wünschte sich mehr und
schnellere und schwerere Waffen und
jetzt als die Infrastruktur so hart
bombardiert wurde aus der Luft die
Ukraine schutzlos war hat Deutschland
geliefert und zwar schnell Hoffnung
macht den Menschen hier auch die Hilfe
die versprochene Hilfe für den
Wiederaufbau das ist ein Lichtblick an
dem sich viele Ukrainer festhalten
hat der Bundespräsident noch besondere
Projekte betont heute
ja bei der Bundespräsident beide
Präsidenten zusammen haben eine
Schirmherrschaft übernommen eher ein
symbolischer Natur aber sie wollen die
Städtepartnerschaften nach vorne bringen
sie wollen beide Völker zusammenbringen
in Europa verorten und haben gesagt dass
auch in der Vergangenheit dass die große
Stärke Europas war dass die Menschen
zusammenfinden sich kennenlernen und
dann eine gemeinsame friedliche Zukunft
hoffentlich entwickeln können Dankeschön
für diese Einschätzung live aus Kiew
Dara Hassan CD
die russischen Angriffe auf die Ukraine
haben nach Schätzungen bereits Schäden
in dreistelliger Milliardenhöhe
verursacht obwohl ein Ende des Krieges
nicht in Sicht ist gaben die Verbündeten
bei einer internationalen Konferenz in
Berlin das Startsignal für den
Wiederaufbau des Landes eine Art
Marshallplan nach dem Vorbild der
us-hilfen für Europa nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg Patricia Wiedemeier
man werde die Ukraine so lange wie es
nötig ist unterstützen und man werde
sich um den Wiederaufbau kümmern der
zugleich eine Modernisierung des Landes
bringen soll das ist eine der
Botschaften des Kanzlers von einem
Marshallplan für die Ukraine einer
Generationenaufgabe ist die Rede auf
Englisch für all die internationalen
Gäste
ucreen that will be in important
producer of green energy es geht um
Investitionen in eine Ukraine die
künftig grüne Energie für die EU liefert
ein Exporteur hochwertiger Produkte wird
ein digitales power-haus ein EU-Mitglied
mit europäischem Recht
schöne Visionen vor Ort in der Ukraine
jedoch brauchen Sie schon jetzt
finanzielle Hilfen 38 Milliarden allein
für das nächste Jahr für die
Wiederherstellung lebensnotwendiger
Infrastruktur für laufende Kosten wie
teuer der gesamte Wiederaufbau wird
fraglich die EU geht von 350 die Ukraine
von 750 Milliarden aus every Europe
jeder Euro jeder Dollar jedes Pfund
jeder Yen es ist eine Investition in die
Ukraine aber auch eine Investition in
die demokratischen Werte weltweit
wer in sein Land investiere investiere
in die EU betonte dann auch der
ukrainische Präsident in einer
Videobotschaft
[Applaus]
die Ukraine tritt für die europäische
Sicherheit ein nicht nur für die
Sicherheit unserer Nachbarn und die EU
kann mit unserer Hilfe auch die
russischen Energieträger ersetzen
neben all der finanziellen Hilfe ging es
natürlich auch um weitere militärische
Hilfen der ukrainische Regierungschef
bedankte sich ausdrücklich für die
deutschen Waffenlieferungen
eine positive Nachricht kommt vom
Gasmarkt der Großhandelspreis für Gas
ist in Europa deutlich gefallen das wird
bei den Verbrauchern allerdings erst mit
Verzögerung ankommen sagt
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck er beriet in
Luxemburg mit seinen europäischen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ging ums
gemeinsame Einkaufen von Gas und das
Hoch umstrittene Thema gaspreisdeckel
morgens um 8 Uhr ist die Welt von
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck in
Ordnung die EU-Minister suchen zwar
weiter nach Lösungen in der Energiekrise
aber dass sie gemeinsam suchen zeigt für
Habig schon Wirkung alleine die
Ausrichtung die Ankündigung dass wir da
was machen werden hat ja unter anderem
das zugeführt dass die Preise
runtergehen gemeinsam etwas machen so
die Botschaft der Energieminister vor
allem gemeinsam als EU ein Teil des
benötigten Gases Einkaufen mit der
Marktmacht Europas will man so den Preis
drücken wenn wir für die
speicherbefüllung im nächsten Jahr
unsere europäische Kraft bündeln dann
stärken wir die Versorgungssicherheit
und wirken preisdämpfend
die Entwicklung des Gaspreises in den
letzten Jahren zeigt das Problem Anfang
2021 lag die Megawattstunde im Schnitt
bei nur 20 Euro dann im August dieses
Jahres nach dem Gas Lieferstopp
Russlands stieg der Preis auf 342 Euro
und viel jetzt auf knapp unter 100 Euro
. ein Gaspreis Deckel also das Festlegen
eines Preises lehnt die Bundesregierung
immer noch ab akzeptiert aber Ausnahmen
wenn Märkte nach oben schießen wenn es
einen externen Schock gibt und die
Märkte offen sind wir Spekulationen dass
man dann andere eingreift die EU bewegt
sich nur langsam auf eine gemeinsame
Energiepolitik zu die dringend notwendig
ist denn die Gaspreise bleiben weiter
ein Problem
soll sich ein chinesisches
Staatsunternehmen an einem Terminal des
Hamburger Hafens beteiligen dürfen
darüber streitet die Bundesregierung
seit Wochen der Kanzler plädiert dafür 6
Ministerien bisher dagegen denn China
bekäme Einfluss auf kritische
Infrastruktur in Deutschland fürchten
Kritiker es besitzt bereits Anteile an
diversen europäischen Hafen Betrieben
auch in Antwerpen und Rotterdam Hamburgs
großen Konkurrenten mehr Auslastung mehr
Container mehr Umsatz das erhofft sich
der Hamburger Hafen jetzt deutet sich
ein Kompromiss an zeigt Ralf Zimmermann
von Siefert
toller Ort heißt das kleinste der vier
Hamburger Containerterminals dieser
Containerhafen liegt mitten im
wirtschaftlichen Herz der Hansestadt die
anstehende Beteiligung der chinesischen
staatsrederei cosco an der
Betreibergesellschaft aber so betonen
Befürworter bedeutet keinen Verkauf von
Grund und Boden oder Infrastruktur der
Hamburger Hafen muss sich mächtig
strecken um die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu
erhalten oder wieder zu verbessern und
wenn man jetzt diesen costcode Deal
verlieren würde cosco vielleicht
Ladung dann abziehen würde an anderer
Standort es gibt Beteiligung in
seebrügge in anderen westhäfen dann wäre
das für Hamburg sicherlich ein weiterer
harter Schlag Hamburg hat lange mit
einer solchen ausländischen Beteiligung
gewartet jetzt scheint der Zeitpunkt der
Entscheidung für Deutschlands
sprichwörtliches Tor zur Welt besonders
unglücklich und dennoch wir sind nicht
naiv wir kennen schauen uns die Welt an
wir sind in der Welt unterwegs wir
wissen was in China für Verhältnisse
herrschen das nehmen wir wahr das wir
respektieren auch dass es Bedenken in
der Bundesregierung gibt wir versuchen
diese auszuräumen selbst die
Kompromisslösung von unter einem Viertel
über die heute in Berlin ein Konsens
gesucht wird ist für manche aus der
Ampelkoalition nicht akzeptabel das ist
ein schwieriger Deal und ich pflege
immer zu sagen ist auch in der Natur
bisschen schwanger gibt es nicht also
entweder man macht ein Geschäft mit den
Chinesen oder man lässt es bleiben und
wir empfehlen dringend das bleiben zu
lassen selbst wenn bis zur morgigen
Kabinettssitzung in Berlin ein
Kompromiss stehen sollte die Fronten bei
der Grundsatzfrage nach strategischen
Beteiligungen dieser Art scheinen noch
lange nicht geklärt
die erste Regierungserklärung von
Italiens neuer Regierungschef in Georgia
Meloni darin bekennt sich die
Parteichefin der rechtsradikalen
fratellit Italia zu den aktuellen Regeln
der EU allerdings werde Sie
Verbesserungsvorschläge machen und auf
italienische Interessen pochen sagt die
45-Jährige die Ankunft von
bootsmigranten in Italien will Meloni
verhindern in nordafrikanischen Ländern
solle geprüft werden ob Menschen ein
Recht auf Asyl haben
es wurden Fehler gemacht und er wolle
den Schaden reparieren das sagt Richi
sunak heute als frischgebackene
Premierminister Großbritanniens König
Charles gab sonak offiziell den Auftrag
eine Regierung zu bilden eine Regierung
die vor großen Herausforderungen steht
Ina Baltes aus London
die zehn in der Downing Street ist jetzt
seine Hausnummer regissonak ist der
dritte Premierminister in zwei Monaten
der hier wohnen wird der wohl schwerste
Job in Großbritannien liegt vor ihm
es sind Fehler gemacht worden und ich
bin gewählt worden als Vorsitzender
meiner Partei und als Premierminister um
diese zu korrigieren
die Zeit drängt gestern gekürt heute
Vormittag im Eiltempo durch die Stadt zu
König Charles jetzt muss der 42-Jährige
sunak Land und Partei und vor allem die
Märkte beruhigen
wirtschaftliche Stabilität und Vertrauen
zum Kern meiner Agenda machen das
bedeutet es liegen schwere
Entscheidungen vor uns
keine konkreten Pläne heute aber ein
drastischer Sparkurs wird erwartet Suna
könnte auch Gesundheits- und
Sozialleistungen kürzen
die Bevölkerung wird es sehr hart
treffen wir haben ja jetzt schon stark
steigende Kosten und fallende
Lebensstandards es ist der tiefste
Absturz seit Jahrzehnten
[Musik]
aus und mit ihr gehen auch einige
Minister das neue Kabinett wird gerade
schon ernannt Regie zunak hat keine Zeit
zu verlieren
etwa 660 Millionen Euro gibt der
deutsche Staat pro Jahr für
parteienalstiftungen aus damit die ihren
Bildungsauftrag erfüllen können für die
SPD ist dass die
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung für die CDU die
Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung auch CSU FDP
Grüne und Linke haben eine die AFD will
dass ihre Stiftung ebenfalls Geld
bekommt und hat geklagt ab heute
verhandelt das Bundesverfassungsgericht
Sarah Tacker hat Details
die Richterinnen und Richter des Zweiten
Senats warnen hier heute über die
Grundsatzfrage ob der Staat auch
politische Bildung für den rechten Rand
fördern muss denn die AFD nahe desideris
rasmus-stiftung für dieselben Zuschüsse
die andere Partei nahestiftung auch
bekommen wir sind die einzige Stiftung
die sich konservativ definiert und vor
diesem Hintergrund ist es eine gesamte
Strömung im Lande die ausgegrenzt ist
mit bis zu 70 Millionen Euro Steuergeld
könnte die Desiderius erasmus-stiftung
unter ihrer Vorsitzenden Erika Steinbach
rechnen und Veranstaltungen die diese
finanzieren im November vor einem Jahr
auf einer Burg am Rhein da ging zum
Wirtschaftspolitik die Stiftung will mit
den Steuermillionen noch größere
Seminare und Tagung durchführen lehr-
und Lernmittel beschaffen zu dem
Forschungsvorhaben und Stipendien
vergeben eine solche Förderung für
Rechtsaußen das wollen Vertreter anderer
Parteien unter allen Umständen
verhindern
wir sagen kein Steuergeld für ein extrem
rechten Think Tank eine Kaderschmiede
und das ist die Desiderius Erasmus
Stiftung eine Entscheidung wird hier
nächstes Jahr fallen
und sie wird vermutlich wegweisend sein
denn klar ist gleiches muss
grundsätzlich gleich behandelt werden
garantiert das Grundgesetz klar ist aber
auch die AFD wird vom Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet und in der Ina stehen den
Stiftung wirken Strategen und Vordenker
der neuen Rechten mit das heißt die
Empfehlung aus Karlsruhe könnte sein in
einem Gesetz festzuschreiben dass nur
solche Partei nahe Stiftung gefördert
werden die wirklich auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes stehen in jedem Fall ein
Grundsatzurteil zur Finanzierung
politischer Stiftung
wie würden Sie es nennen wenn Sie
jemanden richtig toll finden und gerne
auch mal näher kennenlernen würden
Smash sagen die 10 bis 20-jährigen
Hunderttausende von ihnen haben Smash
zum Jugendwort des Jahres gewählt
übrigens gerne auch als Verb genutzt
smashen im Sinn von mit jemandem etwas
anfangen
adidas beendet die Zusammenarbeit mit
dem US-amerikanischen Star Rapper kann
je West wegen antisemitischer Äußerungen
man duldet keinen Antisemitismus und
keine andere Art von Hassrede so der
fränkische Sportartikelhersteller kann
ihr West entwarf seit 2015 sehr
erfolgreich Kleidung und Schuhe für
Adidas die gemeinsame Produktlinie soll
nun eingestellt und Zahlungen gestoppt
werden seit Jahren sorg-west immer
wieder für Empörung
und jetzt Fußball Norbert spannender
Champions league-abend heute ja
allerdings in der könnte Borussia
Dortmund mit einem Sieg sicher ins
Achtelfinale einziehen aber es geht
erstens gegen Manchester City und
zweitens gegen einen exporussen
torkanone erlingerland die Dortmunder
haben aber auch eine Antwort Topscorer
Jude Bellingham
in jedem Gruppenspiel hat er getroffen
der 19 Jahre alte englische
Nationalspieler für Dortmund auch in der
Bundesliga zuletzt wieder treffsicher
macht Eindruck in Manchester
schon beachtlich wir kennen seine
Qualitäten aber wir versuchen unser
Spiel durchzusetzen und zu gewinnen
so wie es im Hinspiel durch das lange
Bein von Erling Holland kurz vor Schluss
gelang der Ex-Dortmunder wird
entsprechend respektvoll in seinem
früheren Heimstadion erwartet
es wird natürlich eine Challenge werden
man hat eine riesen Qualität aber ich
verkaufe die Jungs vor mir und ich freue
mich auf jeden Fall darauf dortmund muss
gewinnen um das Weiterkommen zu sichern
Manchester braucht einen Punkt für den
Gruppensieg
ja und auch Leipzig tritt heute Abend
gegen ein ganz großen Namen an Real
Madrid das Hinspiel das hatte man gegen
den Titelverteidiger noch mit 0:2
vergeigt aber in den letzten sieben
Pflichtspielen da gab es keine einzige
Niederlage mehr
ohne die großen Drei Benzema Modric und
Valverde mangelt es dem Star und sample
der königlichen dennoch nicht an
Qualität das weiß auch leipzig-trainer
Marco Rose real Madrid hat eine
amtierender Champions-League Sieger
amtierende Welt Torhüter also auch ein
Tor haben sie eine Bälle fahren kann
plus Fußball gute Mannschaft die da
kommt glaube ich bei Leipzig wieder
genesen Stürmer Timo Werner seine
Mannschaft muss gewinnen um die
k.o.-phase zu erreichen real hingegen
ist bereits für das Achtelfinale
qualifiziert das
Gruppenerster zu werden das können wir
hier schaffen darauf sind wir hier aus
eine klare Kampfansage des
Titelverteidigers real übrigens seit 16
Pflichtspielen unbezwungen
und die Highlights aller Spiele der
Königsklasse bei uns morgen Abend zu
sehen Sportstudio Champions League 23
Uhr Dankeschön bitteschön ein seltenes
Phänomen gab es heute am Himmel zur
bestaunen zumindest dort wo es die
Wolken zuließen eine partielle
Sonnenfinsternis so wie hier im
Erzgebirge haben sich viele
ortsschaulustige mit Teleskopen und
Spezialbrillen auf den Weg gemacht um zu
beobachten wie der Mond sich vor die
Sonne schiebt kurz Nachmittag erreichte
das Schauspiel seinen Höhepunkt
irritierender Oktober es wird zunehmend
wärmer in den nächsten Tagen mehr dazu
gleich beim Wetter von ostentherly Anne
gallinek begrüßt sie um Viertel im
heute-journal und wir wünschen Ihnen
noch einen schönen Abend und alles Gute
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter mit zunehmender
Erhitzung verschiebt sich der letzte
Sommertag immer weiter nach hinten
Sommertag ist mit 25 Grad mindestens
definiert und das wird in dieser Woche
mehrfach erreicht schuld daran ist die
Hitze die sich im Süden Europas
angesammelt hat und die wird angezapft
von diesem umfangreichen tief auf dem
Atlantik und wird über Spanien über
Frankreich danach Deutschland
verfrachtet das kennen Sie vielleicht
aus dem Sommer diese Wetterlage
wiederholt sich jetzt und im Südwesten
in der Nacht kommt Regen auf das
verschiebt sich weiter nach Nordosten im
Osten ist es trocken bei Temperaturen
von 13 Grad im Südwesten und vier Grad
in der norddeutschen Tiefebene morgen am
Vormittag ist der Regen noch vorhanden
vor allem der Südhälfte sonst nach
Norden in trocken mit sonnigen
Abschnitten und am Nachmittag ist es
dann überall trocken und auch im Süden
kommt die Sonne hervor
Temperaturen schon mal bis 23 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands und 14 Grad nach
Südosten hin noch Würmer wird's in den
nächsten Tagen Donnerstag bis 24 Grad
Freitag bis 26 Grad und damit ein
schöner Abend